well let's talk grey's anatomy are there
any surprises coming up
yes i mean so if anybody who watches the
show knows
yeah oh we had some people freaking out
when i announced you earlier
oh really well this season they'll know
it's been wild because we had mcdreamy
back like the first episode
so we have i've been telling everyone
and i think they just think i'm
promoting the show to like watch live
but
watch live because we have so many
crazy unexpected people coming back that
you wouldn't imagine
and it got announced that sarah drew
plays uh april kepner is coming back
from episode two
um we have a lot of surprises this
season that's kind of cool um
well has playing a tv doctor made you a
hypochondriac i'm
this is coming from one i'm like oh my
god i probably have cancer my finger
hurts like i'm i'm
i get very nervous yeah so the cast
always talks about this we are
super paranoid we know every way that
you can die
um and it's worse when you're pregnant
because if you're
if you're pregnant on our show something
will go wrong you can't just have like a
normal pregnancy so me pregnant i was
like i know everything that could happen
and so that's when it gets really
stressful uh being pregnant in general
though i was scared of everything i was
like oh god what is that yeah what does
that feel and then being in a pandemic
pregnant yeah it's actually super fun
andy i hear that you google symptoms do
you do that
all the time yeah i mean i was doing it
last night as a matter of fact
that's amazing well do you just need a
cream for it are you good
i'm just kidding the rash is clearing up
kelly
i'm just kidding no i webmd people are
like don't google and i'm like then why
don't you create webmd
is my question why did you create these
things for me to not look up
um yeah i would totally be like that on
your show what's helpful in offset is
that our executive bruises are
doctors oh there's a lot of times i'm
like does this mole look okay
and they're like just stop asking me
they're like google they're our google
yeah they're getting a check up on set
yeah that's amazing
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever
[Music]